it's the anniversary of the discovery of  the insane bishop sycamore scheme and  hbo is now making a documentary on it  called bs high just to refresh this team  scammed their way into convincing espn  that they were one a legitimate school  and two a school that had multiple d1  prospects they did this and got their  game televised on espn they ended up  losing 58-0 against img i mean the  school's founder was probably one of the  best khan artists ever players were  apparently lured to this school because  they were promised to be a part of a  netflix documentary not only was there  no tv show there weren't even buildings  or classrooms